he calls himself wait time out is it
weird that i'm standing next to you
like we're gonna tell the story together
when i don't know which
i'm just gonna go stand over there
mm-hmm
here i am
next to my pal
please continue
he calls himself
the bull
but nobody knows that because he's the
last person anybody would think is
running guns and drugs
ceo criminal okay so we're basically
talking about victor maitland you
talking about the villain from beverly
hills scott gray hair gentlemen very
dark-skinned capricorn nothing like that
at all mainland owned a gallery and
lived in a city sure but he was selling
drugs on the side okay does it have to
be a movie character if you want us to
understand yes it would help us
enormously okay fine
victor maitland
so i was an investigator at a private
security firm i was working for an
insurance claim company i get sent out
to take photos of a worker's comp claim
i stumble across this smooth swole
brother named alan decker he's hiding
across the street watching the same
complex she got pictures
i got pictures we pulled our stuff
together
so we working in close quarters
sparks start to fly until as old as time
and we can deny the heat any longer you
can skip this part it's disgusting
it was exciting and sexy
we felt like these moral crusaders you
know
so we about to tell a delivery van and
one of his muscle heads is about to make
a drop talk about a serious crime
something goes wrong it's a gun fight
one of the goons leaves a gun at the
scene
that was it we had a literal smoking gun
but nobody wanted to believe anything
bad about this guy the cops were more
concerned how we found a gun with
missing serial numbers that's when we
knew
we had to do it alone
and we were intoxicated by it
yeah that was the night accident you got
to strike when the iron's hot
i got caught up in the moment and said
yes his cousin nipsey is ordained and
drove up from bakersfield i still owe
her an engagement ring
a honeymoon
we figured that'd be time but no matter
how careful we thought we were being his
goons would always find us
oh
that's when i realized
the only way we stay alive is if we
split up
one of the toughest decisions i ever
made in my life he broke up with me on a
post-it note no
like when burger broke up with carrie
i'm sorry i can't don't hate me
yes
so i realized i had nothing else to lose
so i came back to finish the job
and here we are enough
you've painted a pretty picture but you
forgot one thing
shoot what is her real name
is it prince oh
yeah it'd probably be best if she told
you that nah you need to tell me right
now
you are very close to my face tell me
things are about to get weird
they're not about to get weird gus
they're weird
it's time for you and i to take a very
short but meaningful walk
fine
we'll be back
i didn't know if he was even still alive
i realized the whole thing was just the
intensity of the moment and i needed to
get on with my life
and i did
i met gus
and i cannot lose him
so we need to find him and stop him
before he realizes what he's getting
into
okay it's fine um
i'm gonna change selena you douse the
fire o'hara you're driving because these
men are not gonna save
[Music]
you themselves that i'm not telling the
truth i know you know they just don't
have it if you risk the deception you
learn how to bend your words